this is elema the Bell bearing Hunter
Bell bearings allow you to interact with
the dead spirits of important NPCs and
it's at their locations that we find
this vengeful Spirit who murdered
countless instructors and most but
eventually this murderer was captioned
and instead became known as Elena of the
Briar Briars are a type of thorn and as
we recently discussed Thorns are a mark
of the guilty and so wound around the
weapon shield and armor of element were
iron Breyers which marked him as a
criminal to be sentenced to death
element was due to be beheaded at the
Shaded Castle whose castellans have this
long-storied history as executioners but
right as he was about to be put to death
he snatched The Executioner's own blade
and began wielding it with the battle
skills of his homeland which enabled the
blade to dance through the skies the
element is a Spartan Warrior from ear
kite a domain that vanished long ago but
now element is lured over a new domain
that is until you come along